[музика]
Привіт друзі З вами я пані Ліда і мій
друг ведмежатко бо сьогодні ми рухаємося
далі І в нас нова цікава літера а
називається вона дуже дивно яд чи не
нагадує вона вам якусь іншу літеру
у вас на дошці є підказка ведмежатко Ану
Поглянь юбоджу літеру И
наступну новеньку йод так вони справді
дуже схожі але літера й має щось
особливе давайте повторимо як
називається ця літера йод
Повторіть будь ласка друзі йод
молодці гарно ось послухайте про неї
вірш Ти хто Я не хто а буква й що мене
не сплутать з и я купив
мир невеликий невеликий Подивіться ось
який що ж це за берет у літери й ось він
бачите такий справді наче капелюх має
літера й
Давайте ми з вами подумаємо які слова
починаються з літери йод і звуку й
й йогурт Ось він йогурт
[музика]
я дуже-дуже люблю їсти і йогурт він
смачненький так-так вірно ще ось
Подивіться друзі тут на картинці в нас є
йод така речовина яка допомагає
загоювати рани Гаразд давайте ще
подумаємо
слова у яких є літера й звук й
наприклад
чайник або чай
[музика]
лінійка Ви чуєте звук й
добре і наступне слово
майка і знову звук й всередині слова
і є ще імена з цією літерою йод і звуком
й наприклад Андрійко
Йосип
Матвій
Віталій
Олексій
є багато імен у яких є літера й звук й
А зараз друзі Давайте спробуємо скласти
з цією літерою склади так як ми вже
вчилися з вами робити ось наприклад У
нас є літера а
і
Літера й звук й
давайте подивимося і прочитаємо що у нас
вийде який склад ведмежатко
ой ой
[музика]
ми можемо вигукнути ай
ми навчилися читати а якщо ми підставимо
попереду буквочку
[музика]
звук д Давайте спробуємо прочитати слово
яке в нас утворилося
Дай
вже з трьох літер в нас вийшло слово дай
молодці а якщо першу літеру ми замінимо
на іншу і спробуємо прочитати слово яке
утворилося ведмедику
гей вірно ми утворили слово Гай так
такий гайочок де можна прогулюватися і
насолоджуватися природою молодці
А зараз ми ще зробимо дещо попереду ми
поставимо іншу літеру ось цю ви зараз
прочитаєте
Давайте спробуємо
зайці додамо літеру К і в кінці
поставимо а і утворили слово
зайка маленьке
Зайченя де всередині слова ми бачимо
літеру й звук й Давайте порахуємо
скільки у слові зайка буквочок
ведмедику допомагай один два три чотири
п'ять
літер 5 пальчиків і 5 літер А скільки
звуків Ми чуємо з а й к а теж 5 5 літер
і 5 звуків у цьому слові Ну що ж ви
сім'ї навчилися читати і складати і
Склади і слова А зараз час на загадки
будьте уважно ви знаєте що загадки можна
придумувати і самостійно От зараз я щось
загадаю А ти ведмедику Відгадай будь
ласка що я загадала
він буває
фруктовий
буває вершковий
в таких пластикових баночках для
дорослих і для малюків він дуже-дуже
корисний що це
Я знаю знаю це йогурт вірно і попереду
слова йогурт стоїть літера й звук й
йогурт вірно і наступна загадка
неначе паровоз гуде шумить кипить і Пара
йде смачний заварює нам чай хто ж він
такий Звідки йде пара і допомагає нам
заварити смачний чай Це чайник і у слові
чайник те ж чуємо звук й
і наступна загадка
живе у морі синім Та не тюлень це і не
можеш Я підкажу вам це рибина Ну а
зовуть цю рибу
вірно якщо хтось не здогадався ми вам
підкажемо йорж і рибка йорж і її назва
починається зі звуку й
Гаразд друзі
молодці а зараз ще одна загадка що
потрібно взяти щоб зробити смачний омлет
готується омлет Хто знає друзі
потрібно взяти
яйця у слові яйце теж є звук й вірно
давайте приготуємо з вами омлет візьмемо
яйця ведмедику розбиваємо яйце
заколотимо заколотимо Так збиваємо
взбиваємо взбиваємо що ми додаємо до
омлету хто пам'ятає Хто бачив як мама чи
бабуся чи хтось готує омлет так додаємо
туди молочка збиваємо далі ведмедику
допомагай так збиваємо збиваємо потім
додаємо борошно підсолимо і знову
зіб'ємо І в нас буде смачний омлет
вилимо його на пательню
підсмажимо він буде рости і рости рости
рости рости і виросте смачний смачний
омлет з яйця Гаразд друзі а тепер ще
одне завдання Скажіть будь ласка
яким одним словом можна назвати трамвай
і
тролейбус що це Як ви думаєте До речі у
слові трамвай і у слові
тролейбус теж є звук й
що це друзі вірно все це друзі транспорт
яке ми можемо пересуватися у місті а
зараз час на гру Нумо побавимось зараз я
буду вам називати Слова
які мають звук й А ваше завдання
плескати у долоні якщо ви його почуєте у
слові якщо ні то ми не плескаємо
ведмедик буде трішки вам підказувати
друзів Ви готові але я сподіваюся що ви
справитеся і самостійно отже
майка
плескаємо молодці лінійка
є супер
дорога
непласкаємо у слові дорога не має звука
й
Матвій
плескаємо супер гарна молодці я й це і
знову долоньки ласкаємо
немає добре їжак
не плескаємо
чайник
є всередині слова звук й їдальня
так мене плескаємо добре йогурт і
ведмедик знову плескає своїми лапками
Чайка
добре І ще одне слово
лійка і знову плескаємо у долоньки Ну що
ж друзі Ви молодці Ми побачили з вами у
гру послухали загадки і відгадали їх і
вивчили нову буквочку яка називається як
ведмедику ти запам'ятав
буквочка йод
пригадайте які слова ви запам'ятали з
нашого заняття на літеру й А нам час
прощатися ведмедиком Ну що ж Бувайте На
все добре па-па
[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами пані Настя і ми
зараз з вами зробимо цікаву гру ми
будемо робити нашими руками різні рухи
давайте з вами розберемо приготуєте ваші
пальчики сядьте собі зручно Приготуйте
долоньки А тепер давайте приготуємо
пальчики і ось так їх порозминаємо Добре
тепер зібрали їх до купки і
і ще зібрали і розкрили ще зібрали і
чудово А тепер давайте струсимо наші
кисті Ось так наче тут попала Водичка і
мені струшуємо так давайте дві одночасно
А тепер по черзі
чудово добре ну що ж це ти зручно так
щоб ви могли доторкатися до ваших
колінок добре І тепер повторюйте за мною
першими будемо плескати себе Ось так по
колінках
так
Приєднуйтесь до мене
чудово
і тепер міняємо наш рух і ми будемо
плескати ось так навх
чудово
усіх виходить
якщо в когось не виходить то можете
зробити це повільніше Ось так і тоді
коли вже виходить то можна
пришвидшуватись
[музика]
це дала а тепер ми будемо міняти робимо
весь
плес і на хрест
поколінка
по колінках ще раз
два три раз і два а тепер давайте
трошечки пришвидшимось
це не просто але я впевнена що у вас
усіх дуже гарно виходить
так інші трошки швидше
чудово і міняємо рух Зараз ми будемо
робити Ось так ми будемо однією рукою
плескати себе по Колінці а іншою рукою
Ось так де грудна клітина так Спробуйте
і раз два раз два і швидше
[музика]
так чудово
і тепер
ми міняємо робимо плесь Права рука на
правій Колінці а ліва рука на грудній
клітині і міняємо плесь поміняли клесь
поміняли і ще
[музика]
так
і трошечки пришвидшуємось раз два раз
два раз два
так молодці
А тепер міняємо ми робимо плесь і робимо
нахрест поміняли клесь навхрест
Леся на хрест і
Спробуйте самі
або в своєму темпі Можливо ви робите
повільніше
або можете зробити це швидше якщо ви
зрозуміли як це робиться
супер
чудово мали ці Ну і тепер міняємо наш
рух ми будемо робити Ось так плескати
себе по коліна і колечко
долонька кулачок долонька кулачок
долонька кулачок А тепер швидше раз два
раз два раз раз два продовжуємо
і ще трошки швидше
Окей добре Тепер міняємо одна вправа
долонька інша рука кулачок і поміняли
поміняли ще
[музика]
і пробуємо пришвидшитись
і ще швидше
[музика]
і є молодці
чудова робота
була рада вас бачити па-па
[музика]